باتجاه منطقه جزان النجار وغيرها من
المناطق التي انسحبت منها اليات الاحتلال
فيها كثير من تفاصيل المعاناه والالم حيث
المشاهدات العديده والكثيره من هؤلاء
الذين استطاعوا الوصول الى تلك المناطق عن
شهداء ما زالت جثامينهم في الطرقات اضافه
الى شهداء ايضا تحت انقاض المنازل التي
قصفتها قوات الاحتلال مع بدايه العمليه
العسكريه البريه في محافظه خان يونس في
هذه اللحظات تم احضار خمسه جثامين لشهداء
من عائله النجار على ما يبدو من منطقه
جزان النجار نتعرف على هذه الحاله يعني من
اين اتيتم بهذه الجثامين في خانيونس
اللهم صلي على سيدنا محمد من مدرسه محمد
الضره ب جزان النجار بالقرب من مجمع
المحاكم خانون معنا خمس شهداء هيهم
موجودين على
الكاره استشهدوا تقريبا في 8 واحد اللي
فات ول صعوبه الموقف صعوبه المشهد اللي
هناك ما قدرناش نصهم تواصلنا مع كل الجهات
المعنيه والمختص زي الصليب الاحمر والهلال
وال والمستشفى والاسعافات ما ما حدا قدر
يصل هناك وحاولنا بكل الطرق اننا نصل ما
قدرنا قبل يومين ن درينا انه هناك في
امكانيه انه حدا يروح بس يقدر يعني قد ما
يقدر يخطف حاله بسرعه يعني يروح يجيب اي
غرض ويجي فاسنا على حالنا وبموقف شخصي زي
ما انت شايف يعني رحنا هناك والصبح توجهنا
الساعه 8 الصبح ودخلنا المدرسه هناك
وطلعنا خمس جسس والشهد هذول 25 يوم في
مدرسه امنين كانوا امنين والله غلابه كلهم
غلابه هذول ولايه وبنات ابوهم
مهم استشهدوا وفي غيرهم لسا مش قادرين ن
طولهم في غيرهم كمان مش انه يعني انه يعني
خلصوا لا ضايل احنا هدول عشان احنا اهلهم
جبناهم دفنا واحد ودفنا واحد في الشارع
وفي في ثمان جسس في بص محروقين مش قادرين
نجيبهم كمان يعني عمليه الانتشار مستمره
والمشهد بالتاكيد بتفاصيله مؤلم وقاسي
جدا اسماعيل ابو عمر
الجزيره خونس